hello everyone my name is caleb denby
and today we're going to be analyzing
some of the games from the candidates
tournament in 2020
and 2021 two years for the price of one
tournament
um today i want to look at how things
shook up between
the two biggest challengers to nepo in
the back half of the tournament
that is fabiano caruana and aneesh geary
fabian anish played some really
interesting really creative chess in the
back half of this tournament
but nepo was just too strong too solid
and they could not catch him
that being said this is the game that
essentially knocked fabi out of the
running
anish geary was the one to do it let's
see how it happened
we got e4 c5 knight f3
e6 and the open sicilian
uh anish follows up with knight f6 we
get knight c3
and knight c6 and simply a3
so the four knight sicilian uh and
this is the game that i would be
studying
if i played the sicilian really any
variation in the sicilian because
a niche does an absolutely model job of
handling
uh white's play in this game uh anish
does everything right
takes every opportunity offered to him
and wins the game with style so let's
see what that looks like first of all
a3 uh this is always sort of a move you
can expect in
the sicilians whenever white it wants to
be a little bit more cagey doesn't want
to admit
to what line they're hoping to play a3
tends to be a useful move it keeps
both of these pieces out of the b4
square and white can even consider
launching this pawn down the board on
his own sometimes
also by the way uh anticipating perhaps
a future b5 b4 attempt
so what do you do with black when your
opponent is being sort of flexible and
cagey well
you stay simple you develop your pieces
like a niche does bishop e7
we get bishop e3 now by favi and anish
simply castles you know no reason to do
anything
too crazy uh fabian continues now with
bishop e2
and we're still in well truck uh well uh
trotted land here a well-trodden path um
with plenty of games reaching this
position before uh anish now
opts for this structure with d6
sometimes
black players will play with d5 here
hoping to break in the center
and sort of equalize right away but
denise chooses this rather interesting
move d6 and i think this is indicative
of a niche fighting for a win in these
games he wants to keep the structure a
little bit more flexible
and wants there to be some more play in
the position against fabi
and now fabi does bring out his novelty
as he tended
to do in the back half of this
tournament always the one
to break tradition first with queen to
d3
and so i assume anish had a pretty good
idea of what was going on up until this
point i'm sure this was all stuff he had
in his prep
but queen to d3 might have been a little
bit of a surprise for him at least just
a little bit of one
so the question is well what do you do
when your opponent plays something that
you don't know
and the answer is you respond exactly
like anish does
so in order to figure out what you
should do against queen d3
we're going to look at the main ideas
here so there are a couple main ideas
one of which being to push this pawn out
to f4 this is a pretty common way for
white to kind of attack
this structure of e6 d6 white can play
f4 and go after
f5 or e5 and here there are a couple
moves for black black can consider
breaking in the middle right away with
e5 but another really useful move here
is bishop d7
just to sort of shore up the queen side
a little bit
play a6 next and eventually later on
down the line
consider pushing b5 so against queen d3
this is the kind of move that doesn't
really introduce too many new threats
into the position
um if anything it's looking to control
these light squares a little bit more
so anish's move of bishop d7 makes
perfect sense
you don't spend too long thinking about
it even though it's a move you haven't
seen
you just stick to the basics and follow
your opening
plan fabi now continues with f4
and we're approaching a position that
anish might be a little bit more
familiar with
now we get e5 by anish giri the perfect
response to f4
in many cases for black is to play e5
you don't allow white
the opportunity to sort of attack your
structure instead you're the one
breaking first cementing this pawn on e4
keeping white's pieces
out of the game and fighting for some
squares of your own in the center
bobby captures on c6 and we get bt b
takes c6
and now king side castles by fabi
and here is where uh the opening play
sort of starts to turn into middle game
play
so the structure is beginning to develop
here um
you know the the time of you know fluid
pawn structures
is running short here it's time to make
some decisions
so as black we have this interesting
looking structure in the center
now there's one obvious weakness in the
center uh in the structure and that is
the d6 pawn
fabi's going to try to bring the pieces
to the d file go after this pawn
and make life difficult for black
so the question is how do we find active
counter play
well the answer is somewhat surprising
and that is in e takes f4 this is a very
interesting move by anish
at first glance i would say it's a
little bit counterintuitive now why is
that
well it's drawing white's bishop to the
f4 square where it's attacking your
biggest weakness in the center
but anisha's reasoning is quite sound
here he wants to get a very powerful
knight onto the e5 square
and then use this knight to sort of
launch the rest of his play with the
strong knight in the center he'll be
able to play a lot more freely
and go after white's weaknesses on e4
and down the b file a lot more easily
so bishop f4 does make a threat which is
why we see bishop e6 here
fabi now continues out with queen g3
making some rather nasty looking threats
uh and now anish follows up with the
nice
tactical idea of knight d7 and this sort
of shows you
how deep a niche actually saw into the
position
knight d7 is not a move you he just came
up with on the fly he had to sort of see
this coming
from a ways away now what's the point of
knight d7 it looks like it's not really
solving
any of our problems here well the fact
of the matter is if you do play bishop
h6
simply bishop f6 is going to defend if
rook takes we do have queen takes
to keep the defense and white isn't
getting very far
and the slightly more obvious one why
not just take the free pawn
and the answer here is that black uh
does have this nice resource of queen v6
forking uh the king and the pawn
and black is actually going to be a
little bit better here so let's just
take a quick look
takes takes check king h1 queen b2
and there's simply too many weaknesses
here on the queen side for white to
handle
uh okay so knight d7 really nice move
uh stopping both threats at the same
time and
preparing to continue the plan of knight
e5 now we get rook a to d1
and anish comes up with a really great
idea here as well
simply rook to e8 and this move
and when i tell you that this move is
deep i mean this move
is deep so what is the point of rook e8
well
the point is that's um
what is the point of rk8 uh gotta find
my line here
so the point is after queen v6 check
there's bishop e3 and if we were
to capture on b2 then there is this
really nice idea of knight to d5
and the point now is that we're
attacking this undefended bishop
on e7 and in return if we capture the
knight
white has this amazing idea of forking
the queen
and checkmate winning substantial
material
so anish sort of sees this idea from
afar here
and says okay that's fine i'll play
rookie 8
defend my bishop and then maybe i can
start thinking about threatening
this move queen to b6 check with knight
d5
being dealt with really deep stuff here
going on in the subtle mysterious move
rook to e8 defending against knight d5
alright fabi though is no slouch sees
these ideas coming and plays king to h1
now the tactics are sort of falling
behind here and as a niche
we really need to start defending our
d-pawn it's attacked three times and
only defended once
so how are we going to do it a lesser
player might play the move queen
to b6 attacking this pawn and just
trying to find counter play over here
but anish finds a really really
interesting move and if you've ever
played
any of those like sliding block puzzle
games where you have to slide the blocks
around to get one block out
that's sort of what a niche does here
with the queen and the two rooks
as it is they're not the most actively
placed this rook
is defending this bishop yes but it
could be a little bit more active
but the queen is sort of in the way and
same for this rook maybe this rook wants
to come out this way
but it just can't do it yet so anish
plays queen to b8 rather than queen to
b6 it has the same idea
of pressuring the pawn on b2 but it also
supports this knight
coming to e5 we see b4
and now knight e5 stops up all this
pressure and now
b5 is the interesting idea by fabi but
now anish does start to do this fun
little game
with the queen and the rooks and now
that the queen is out of the way we
bring the rook to c8
bobby captures we capture now knight d5
does hit this bishop so we bring the
queen all the way back over
and now this rook is free as well not
the most standard way of developing the
rooks
but whatever works i guess
and now fabi plays the move c3
and thus far things have gone pretty
much perfectly for
black yes you do have this one nagging
weakness
on d6 but you know in the meantime
you've managed to really
make just a shattered mess out of
white's pawns on the queen side and this
shattered pawn structure is going to be
more than enough compensation
for your own weakness on d6 and this is
what i mean when i say that this is a
model sicilian game
by anish you don't get too caught up in
defending your own weakness you're
always looking for ways
to counter attack rather than simply
defend
uh in this position now anish develops
the other rook with rookie to c8
we get rook c1 by fabi now knight g6 is
going after this guy
so bishop d2 and now bishop h4 and
with pressure on the c pawn white has
almost entirely forgotten
about attacking the d pawn and now black
is activating the remaining pieces
queen e3 rook c5 cuts off this queen's
access to a7
c4 now is a very committal decision by
white so with c4 something should really
stick out to you
and that is the fact that you are
blocking off your light squared bishop
and giving up
on dark squared control so as such
what should black do well black should
go after the dark squares and that's
what anish does with h6
looking for bishop g5 now queen b3
still bishop g5 is forcing the dark
squared bishop off the board
take take queen g3 queen d8 to defend
the pawn
and now after rook c to d1 it's maurice
ashley's
favorite move in all of chess that's
right it's bishop takes knight
anish waits for fabi to commit to this
pawn to c4
leaving himself with a bad bishop and
then trades off all of the other minor
pieces
in short order now after e takes d5 it's
just
a good night against a bad bishop and
anish
is cruising to win this game knight f4
queen f2 rook 8 to c7 we're never taking
this bishop don't worry
uh rook d4 queen e8 now
and fabi wins one pawn uh
and the rest is sort of history just
gets entirely too active
for uh white to handle and then rook a2
is
getting into some really nasty stuff
here on the second rank if you capture
this rook
of course you're getting met with queen
h4 queen e1
and queen e4 at the very very least
uh so rook b1 is bobby's clever idea
instead
to play for checkmate if you capture the
queen uh geary simply retreats this rook
now we get rookie one f5 to attack the
bishop
and king f7 is again just more nastiness
by anish giri bringing the rook around
the other way um rick e3 tries to to
hold it all together
we get the check king g1 and then the
last move of the game
go ahead pause at home if you want to
try to find it there are plenty of ways
to win here though
but this one is sort of the most stylish
and of course
that move is knight takes g2 simply
ripping things open
and fabi resigns in light of the fact
that his king
is getting absolutely murdered so really
impressive game
by anish giri of course he didn't quite
make it to the finish line with nepo
pulling away with some clutch wins in
the back
half of the tournament but uh really
excellent play by anish in this game
uh this absolutely model sicilian uh
forcing weaknesses in white's camp
all of a sudden everybody forgot about
the d6 pawn being weak
and then just easily converting the
position
that's all i have for you guys today
thank you so much for watching and i
will see you
next time